this is the message Rob where are you
are you over there I'm not coming oh
you're not coming house is because I
pushed you out and the chair went with
you baby
well fine I don't need you anyway talked
about this myself
good luck you'll probably make spelling
mistakes even though you don't even need
to spell anything all right this is the
massage damn it oh I need you I need to
dispel check I need you to keep me
grounded on the ground I will we mean it
fucking leave you but I'll come in
anyway sigh ha ha ha ha hey just ah so
worth it do it on your own ok just have
to look at my feet at my feet hey this
is the message and that whole first part
is gonna be edited out uh there's some
nice little cryptic foreshadowing as
usual no part of course ah but even has
a robot voice yes and Steve had one
scene at the end so summed it up or
they're just like goofing off and the
gems are just like that kind of just
feels like the show like there's just
big shit going on it's like you know
just keep the people happy just smile be
like heaven real like really good that's
why politics the more that's probably a
lot of things just keep the people happy
when really there's going on but yeah
this is one where they're getting a
message out of this device and they
Stevens dead uh which I I'm just gonna
called Greg now because I think they
said Greg like five times in this
episode am i okay I'm not forgetting
that name now uh thinks that you know
the message can be dug through its audio
equipment and they doubt in but they
goes back and says hey let's use the
video equipment and it works and it's a
message from this is from lapis who is
just like shits coming man Earth's going
down not going on
and yeah you're pretty much fucked um
and I like how the end of the messages
just don't resist yeah I love that do
only lead to more death um
and so they even though they're all
panicky and tried to figure out what to
do
oh the message yeah guard it goes and
thanks Greg for you which is you know I
I like that thought that was pretty cool
um he brings up a good point like it
kind of shocked me when they're just
like oh the vans battery went dead and
the three figure out they can charge it
I'm like no wait a minute yeah ever just
like fuck this shit and just leave and
I'm like the hell I'm like like he had
that great line when it comes out it's
like you guys never give up on anything
except for me and I'm like yeah why is
that we know again thinking back to
their history and what they know about
him you know like kind of what's looking
more and more like their leader I mean
Rosa's sounding more and more kinda like
their leader just kind of gave up
everything like you know to be with him
and so I gave up her physical form to
become his child and stuff like that
they don't hang out with him much you
know and even with an offense like she
did and then she got sore this is my
family so your dad that successful mom
does not like ex mom does not want to
like hang out like it's almost like I
think there's this resentment kind of
towards him that they don't straight-up
say but they do really feel it and it's
kind of passive-aggressive do ya just
seems like when those post-divorce
scenarios where moms lay it's like a
movie where moms like the rich lawyer
and then you get the you know dad who's
like down on his luck but he's kind of
the goofy dad that the kid likes and the
mom just has to put up with it mm-hmm um
but at the same time he's I'm he seems
to be surviving fine whatever he's got
like the car wash and stuff like that
he's not super rich or anything but he's
also not saving the world or anything as
a waiter do it he does have a van and
audio live edit of him uh have we were
seen his place I'm trying to remember
yeah I don't know if we have it's like
always just been either a storage locker
or a van ah summer home his summer van
YUM but uh yeah I so so you get this
nice little
dick bit in this um and it's really good
they have the nice foreshadowing they
still have this kind of nice emotional
Arkin as well I the only quote-unquote
problem that I have with it is like it
starts off with them singing about lapis
and that was night through music and all
this and then he kind of sings again
about how he's feeling and I was kind of
like you could have scrapped that I
think he said it best that's a b-side
hey you know you didn't really need that
of song hater well no no I love there's
no you family left in your life is it um
not not with that song sir that was a
b-side um actually thought was very
funny like no like that B's you know
what being on the b-side though still
means you made the tape suck on that
tapes are dead oh now they're gonna come
back it's like vinyl yeah I'll be like
vinyl which I still don't get um but
hipsters dude lots of hipsters but yeah
I mean I get that's a nitpick it wasn't
like oh that went on forever and that
was awful it's just kind of like I
thought you didn't need it like he kind
of got it very quick um you know how are
you feeling and stuff but uh yeah I like
the I like the idea of how do you just
sort of figure out the sound I like
little jokes in beginning of trying to
stop the sound I love her hitting it
quiet
lifts it up goes right back into the
sound I like the sound it makes out
Stevens mouth way puts his hand in it so
I I kind of like that I like the
experimenting and figuring out how to
like how they assume it's amethyst fault
yeah this a prank no I hate it
you know something it may be kind of
subject change but can made me realize
too so amethyst obviously must be the
youngest out of all of them and whatever
they live like hundreds or thousands of
years um I'm so now wondering what her
age is now then I mean is she like cuz I
can't looked around thinking like oh you
know late 20s or something like that but
for all we know maybe she's not even in
her 20s yet for all we know you know
like by our standards don't make it
weird man
I have no idea um but ya know it's just
watching it again I was like yeah so she
was a kid band and the age and a
different time and everything is
to make me wonder um but uh they're
saying it's peridot
I'm kind of wondering because she the
last we heard is that she said I'm gonna
report this so she has a higher up so
either it's that higher up or she sent
Mike up there why I'm not sure if they
were saying oh it's peridot whose
commanding the home planet I think
they're just saying it's peridot it may
be given orders yeah yeah okay uh so
cool that means bad shits on the way yay
Oh which is kind of nice you know you
always see the remnant so be good for
goodness sake Oh somebody's coming um
you always see the remnants the
leftovers worshippers you always see the
leftovers of these giant battles and
it's cool and I like lead into your
imagination but at the same time you're
like yeah what would these battles be
like again why is the family aware yeah
we're gonna freak out so much over that
in the end it's gonna be like the end of
like Evangelion or something is gonna be
all crayon drawings ruin what's um well
again that's the advantage of this kind
of show where the drawings are very
simple and very minimally is that you
can you can really throw a lot into
these big action scenes and visuals and
stuff because the drawings are so easy
to do so then you can move on and you
can play with scale and get all this
great stuff again kind of like that last
gravity falls we saw the to partner with
the weird of me
we're mageddon today was amazing so um
yeah I can't cuz like wasn't wait you're
the first or second episode where that
giant eye or ball whatever was coming
and even that felt kind of big even
though all they were doing they were
throwing amethyst at it but it kind of
felt like oh that's kind of doomsday ish
and like what I really think about we
didn't see that much but it still felt
big so be nice we basically know her
stories and seeing that you know it's
like Lord of the Rings I always see the
giant statues like all crumbled and in
pieces and you hear the stories but
eventually we're gonna have a moment
it's gonna be like freakin Minas Tirith
like gonna have like black riders I'm
like fell peas and we're gonna have like
trolls and orcs and shit and well maybe
not orgs but you know that does make me
realize so this is what I really loved
about especially the books
uh Lord the Rings was mythology well now
not only the mythology but they start
off small and they they make the small
stuff very likeable and very enjoyable
bigger and big and it grows but yeah you
just keep adding stuff and you want to
see if they're here I wouldn't have
thought there was that's what I'm saying
cosmic super battle like just around the
bend like at the beginning of this show
but now I'm just like holy shit yeah so
I really like that I like that the
carrot they start simple and you like
these characters and you like their
prompts and even the action that they do
have really now the grand scheme of
things does not seem as large as the
stuff they've a talked about and B are
probably going to do so yeah I think
that's very appropriate because then you
build to this big climax that feels
really earned like they've really taken
the time to establish it get it set up
and they don't just throw the action at
you and say be invested you know are too
much information at you they really let
it set and they let it build uh with
every single episode yeah so um try
think of anything else I mean it seems
like lapis is you know a goodie you know
apparently so we think yeah it could be
like me they're just trying to maybe
she's at you the evil one yo it's like
no yo I'm the I'm the one in distress I
really don't know it's gonna have a nice
running the whole thing I'm expecting
way to much from this show cuz I keep
waiting for like a double triple
quadruple cross or something and like
these insane twists but I doubt it's
gonna happen hey you never know again
that is the nice things like lapis is
good like yeah or maybe lapis is the one
controlling all the best ah say yeah I'm
kind of a Taylor seems unlikely but
never know it would be a pretty good
twist
um quickly triggers about maybe not um
but yeah that's uh that's about it and
we will see it the next one beta shits
going down